Hey there everyone!
In this episode I am going to talk about my
personal Top 20 lessons that I learned from
the book "Emotional Intelligence" Why It Can
Matter More Than IQ, by Daniel Goleman.
Does IQ define our destiny?
In his groundbreaking bestseller, Daniel Goleman
argues that our view of human intelligence
is far too narrow.
It is not our IQ, but our emotional intelligence
that plays a major role in thought, decision-making
and individual success.
Self-awareness, impulse control, persistence,
motivation, empathy and social deftness: all
are qualities that mark people who excel,
whose relationships flourish, who can navigate
difficult conversations, who become stars
in the workplace.
With new insights into the brain architecture
underlying emotion and rationality, Goleman
shows precisely how emotional intelligence
can be nurtured and strengthened in all of
us.
Lesson number 1 - Rational and Emotional
It is mentioned in the book that there are
two different bits of intelligence.
Throughout our lives, we make decisions by
being influenced by these two types of intelligence.
Who we are, what we do, our reactions depend
entirely on it.
The underlying reason for our very clever
actions or our irrational but feel-good behaviors
depends on these two types of intelligence.
Lesson number 2 IQ Isn’t As Important As
We Think
IQ can’t get you beyond being a good employee.
It makes you graduate from school, but it
can’t find you a job.
When you go to the job interview, your diploma
cannot answer the questions during the interview.
You need to have good communication with the
person who will hire you.
It all depends on your emotional intelligence.
Lesson number 3 Areas of Emotional Intelligence
Emotional intelligence is responsible for
our motivation, awareness, empathy, and relationships.
They’re all interconnected, and if you’re
bad at one, you’re more likely to be bad
at the others.
Lesson number 4 The Emotional Brain Is Stronger
The outer upper part of our brain is the part
where we make rational decisions, while the
lower part is the part where we make emotional
decisions.
No matter how rational beings we may appear,
we can very easily be deceived by the emotional
brain.
We can find excuses to trick the rational
brain into doing what the emotional brain
wants.
Lesson number 5 Others’ Feelings
Thanks to our empathy, we can truly understand
how others are feeling.
If we could not distinguish between happy
or angry people, there would be incredible
chaos.
Beyond these two basic emotions, we must develop
an ability to empathize.
In the absence of empathy, our communication
aspect is affected very badly.
Lesson number 6 Motivation
Our motivation, which enables us to endure
the problems we face for a long time, is also
a product of emotional intelligence.
We can convince ourselves that we can solve
problems.
We can remain optimistic and have hope for
the future.
Lesson number 7 Awareness
One of our most difficult aspects to develop
is our awareness.
We must practice understanding how we truly
feel.
We must ask ourselves questions.
We must listen to ourselves.
Lesson number 8 Relationships
Relationships cannot be let go.
It must be managed.
This requires mutual tolerance and understanding.
If you know how to resolve conflicts, it turns
into a happy relationship for both parties.
Lesson number 9 Negative and Positive Emotions
Our emotions change every moment, but the
longer negative emotions stay, the more negatively
they affect our lives.
It prevents us from being successful in our
work and relationships.
Fortunately, these feelings are not difficult
to change.
You can learn to turn negative emotions into
positive ones.
Lesson number 10 Productivity
When your emotional intelligence gets stronger,
your creativity starts to increase.
Regardless of your field of work, you will
start to see serious differences in your productivity.
It will increase your performance.
Longer hours allow you to work with the same
efficiency.
Lesson number 11 Emotional Intelligence Is
The Key To Success
Since we cannot live a life independent of
our emotions, the higher our emotional intelligence,
the higher our quality of life will be.
We know that successful managers are experts
in managing their emotional intelligence.
You can also take them as an example.
Lesson number 12 Leadership
A commander cannot direct an entire army by
saying “we are going to war”.
You can’t manage a team by just saying what
to do.
You need to understand your team’s current
feelings and level of motivation.
You should encourage them to work.
You have to use your emotional intelligence
for all of these.
Lesson number 13 Teams
Average talent teams that get along well with
each other are more productive than gifted
teams that don’t get along.
It doesn’t matter how well a team with low
emotional intelligence is in control of the
numbers.
They can’t even decide what to try to do.
Lesson number 14 Stress
Difficulties at work and in our relationships
put us under stress.
Stress makes it difficult for us to find solutions
to problems.
When we can’t find solutions to problems,
we get more stressed.
To get rid of this dead end, we need to know
how to manage our stressful situations.
Lesson number 15 Marriage
The secret of long and happy marriages is
sincerity in your feelings.
If your marriage was not built on this basis
of honesty from the very beginning, it will
begin to crack over the years.
Even small problems become unsolvable.
You have to be emotionally open at the beginning
of the road.
Lesson number 16 Leadership
Leadership does not mean dominance.
Leading your colleagues to a common goal and
making them believe in the reality of this
purpose.
Successful leaders are those who can keep
their team’s motivation alive for many years.
You have to make them desire the work to be
done.
Lesson number 17 Emotions Are All Normal
Anger, hatred, love, happiness…
You can understand when and under what circumstances
these feelings will emerge by following yourself.
You may have these feelings depending on how
you interpret the events you encounter.
The important thing is to be able to react
independently of your feelings.
You may find yourself making promises that
you cannot keep because you are happy, or
you may resort to violence when you are angry.
Lesson number 18 Being able to Express Your
Emotions
Not everyone’s level of empathy can be very
good.
You may be in a difficult situation immediately.
You may feel bad, but people may not understand
it.
In these situations, you may need to express
your feelings a little more directly.
Lesson number 19 You Are Not Your Emotions
Keep doing what you need to do, no matter
how you feel.
Success is achieved by people who cannot give
up no matter what their feelings and thoughts
are.
Don’t let your feelings affect your actions.
Lesson number 20 Timing
As soon as you feel a different emotion, try
to think before you act.
Because emotional intelligence moves faster
than rational intelligence, it can make you
act irrationally and make you say any unnecessary
words.
In this podcast, we discussed the key takeaways
from the book "Emotional Intelligence" by
David Goleman.
We explored the definition of emotional intelligence
and its importance in personal and professional
success.
We also discussed the five components of emotional
intelligence, including self-awareness, self-regulation,
motivation, empathy, and social skills.
Through examples and case studies, we learned
how emotional intelligence can be developed
and improved over time.
Overall, emotional intelligence is a crucial
skill for individuals to develop and can have
a significant impact on their personal and
professional lives.
Thank you all for tuning in!
Until next time, take care!